imagine you've got millions of database
entries across thousands of bigquery
data sets hosted on hundreds of google
cloud projects and you have to search
through all that data to make sure
sensitive data is properly protected
that sounds like a huge deal and to be
honest it's a lot just thinking about it
luckily though automatic dlp makes it a
breeze you can scan across your org with
just a few clicks automatic dlp offers a
slew of new features to configure scans
that meet your business needs so that
you can have even more visibility into
at-risk data in your organization
in our last video what is automatic dlp
we outlined what automatic dlp is
now we'll learn how to configure it and
make it work for your business
to be able to scan your organization
data and create a data profile you need
to create a scan configuration
a scan configuration is where you set
the resource that you want to scan
organization folder or project
which inspection template to use and
what to do with the results
but before we can dive into how to
create a scan configuration let's go
over some resource hierarchy
google cloud resources are organized
hierarchically starting from the bottom
of the hierarchy projects are the first
level resources like bigquery data sets
are associated with individual projects
folders are an additional grouping
mechanism on top of projects folders can
be used to model different legal
entities departments and teams within a
company
folders and projects are all mapped
under the organization resource the
organization resource is the root node
of the google cloud resource hierarchy
and all resources that belong to an
organization are grouped under the
organization node
this provides central visibility and
control over every resource that belongs
to an organization
automatic dlp is designed to operate
across this hierarchy enabling you to
configure it across projects folders or
your organization this gives you
flexibility while minimizing overhead
let's talk a bit about scanning
organizations and folders a maximum of
one scan configuration can be created
for each organization or folder once the
scan configuration is active it will
cover all the data sets and tables in
all the projects below it in the
hierarchy if two or more active scan
configurations have the same project in
their scope the following rules apply
the one that is closest to the project
in the hierarchy will be able to
generate data profiles for that project
so if you want to cover your entire
organization you can just create one
configuration for your org
if you need to have different
configurations for a certain department
or business unit you have that
flexibility too
now let's talk about project level
configurations automatic dlp treats
project level scan configurations
independently of organization and folder
level configurations
this way you can enable project or data
owners to run their own discovery scans
without impacting what the organization
level needs
so a scan configuration that you create
at the project level can't override one
that you create for a parent folder or
organization
let's take a look at an example where
there are three scan configurations here
scan configuration 1 applies to the
entire organization scan configuration 2
applies to the team b folder and scan
configuration 3 applies to the
production project
in this example cloud dlp effectively
generates two sets of profiles for the
production project
one set for scan configuration 2 and one
set for scan configuration three
however even though there are two sets
of profiles for the same project you
don't see them all together in your
dashboard you only see the profiles that
were generated under the purview and
region that you're currently viewing
and speaking of things under your
purview let's talk about roles and
permissions
to turn a scan configuration on at the
oregon folder level you need the dlp
administrator role the project creator
role and either the organization
administrator or the security admin role
on the organization iam policy
viewing data profiles on an organization
or folder will require the dlp data
profiles reader role and the dlp reader
role
that being said it is possible for a
user to create the configuration another
user with higher permissions to grant
profiling access and another user to
monitor the generated profiles
similarly to enable automatic dlp on at
the project level you need the right
project level permissions
okay now that resource hierarchy and
permissions are covered let's get into
the good stuff
as i mentioned before a scan
configuration is where you set the
resource that you want to scan
which inspection template to use and
what to do with the results
configurations can only be created once
for an org and once for any folder but
you always have the flexibility to
change it
first make sure that you're in the
correct organization or project for this
demonstration i'm going to create a
configuration at the organization level
to do that i've got the security admin
role assigned on the organization iam
policy so that i can configure automatic
dlp for the entire org we'll also touch
on the project level scan a bit later
in manage schedules you can set a
scanning schedule for a subset of your
data with details on filters
frequency and conditions filters specify
the subset of your data and you can
identify specific projects data sets or
table ids and regular expressions that
you want to call out which means you can
leave out or only scan any portion of
the data you want like tables that end
in underscore temp
frequency covers whether selected tables
should be profiled how often they should
be profiled and events that will trigger
scanning for example you can specify how
often you want the data reprofiled when
the schema changes like when columns are
removed or when a table has data changes
such as when new data rows are added
finally conditions are set up so that
they must be met before a table is
profiled there are minimum conditions
which are about rows and duration
and time condition for only profiling
tables after a specific date and time
so if you have tables that are created
but not filled until 48 hours later
and you don't want them profiled while
they're empty you consider row condition
though the table must have at least 100
rows before being profiled or must be 48
hours old
managing schedules is considered an
optional step because if you don't set a
new schedule the default schedule will
take over
the default frequency is to pick up new
tables daily and only reprofile monthly
if the schema changes
next you'll need to select an inspection
template to specify the types of
sensitive data to scan for
for today we'll create a new one and
we'll scan for dates of birth
emails and person names
you can also add additional inspection
rule sets if you want to exclude
unwanted findings or include additional
findings
then we'll select a likelihood level if
possible and press continue to finish
our inspection template
keep in mind that if you change an
inspection template that your scan
configuration uses the changes are
applied
only to future scans and any existing
data profiles are not overwritten
so if you edit your template to add an
info type that change only affects
tables that have yet to be scanned
now you get to decide how to manage the
outcome of your scan aka those data
profiles
you have the option to publish to
chronicle
save copies to bigquery
or publish events to pub sub but we'll
talk more about this in an upcoming
video
up next is the service agent container
which is a project that cloud dlp uses
to track billing charges related to
organization and folder level profiling
a service agent is a google managed
service account that automatic dlp uses
to profile data on your behalf
when you create a scan configuration for
your organization or for a folder cloud
dlp requires you to provide a service
agent to authenticate your service agent
must have all the required permissions
to access and profile your data
cloud dlp can automatically create a
service agent for you and if you're
configuring project level profiling
cloud dlp automatically uses your
project's own service agent
for this demonstration we'll create a
new project
last but not least you need to set a
location to store the configuration this
is just the region for where the
configuration will live remember that
regardless of where you store your
configuration when scanning your actual
data automatic dlp will do so in the
same geographic region that your data
lives in this way your data does not
leave its region and data residency is
supported
we're going to go with multiple regions
in the united states for our resource
location
then we'll review this quickly and
create
now you have your scan configuration
saved in your dashboard and it will run
on its own
before we finish let's talk about the
project level configuration i mentioned
before
as we discussed this type of scan
configuration can always profile the
target project and does not compete with
other configurations at the level of the
parent folder or organization
the main difference is that there's no
need to select a service agent container
everything else is the same as with the
organization and folders
now you've seen firsthand how simple it
is to create and deeply customize a scan
configuration for your organization
folder or project
so let's recap
scan configurations is where you set the
resource that you want to scan which
inspection template to use and what to
do with the results
google cloud resources are organized
hierarchically and automatic dlp scan
configurations follow this hierarchy
when scanning
the correct permissions are needed when
turning scan configurations on
scan configurations now include new
options for your org like how often to
scan what to scan or not scan
where to scan and more
then you just turn it on once and let it
run while we take care of the rest join
us next time when we explore how to
manage your scan outcomes in detail
thanks for watching
you